has returned to
the grand finale of this uh exceptional
Workshop
no pressure
are we set up we are set up
second
foreign
hi everyone
pleasure to be the best
talk in this wonderful Workshop
we're gonna talk today
so something like 45 minutes about
uniform version of hardness versus
Randomness and some progress in this and
it's uh based on a joint work with Lydia
who is here and
let's pretend that he's here in the
audience too and with oh hi DJ
and with Ron Ross Bloom from detection
so let's uh remind ourselves of some
context okay if we want to reduce the
randomization BPP equals P ignore
promise issues hiding things under the
rack here so we can use classical
hardness versus Randomness stuff it's
enough to assume circuit oral bounds
right uh non-uniformity cannot speed up
the computation of arbitrary problems in
exponential time that simply that's a
big person and you can use these new
non-black box hardness versus Randomness
Frameworks and like uh make do with the
hardness on almost all inputs like
there's a function computable in
polynomial time and Mild depth second
squared the type for probabilistic time
something fixed polynomial and all but
finitely many inputs and these are
strong assumptions
as you'd expect the second one or at
least variations of it is also necessary
so we're happy
but the motivating question for what we
are going to do today is okay what
happens if we're willing to settle for
less we want to make do with weaker
normal humanly possible assumptions okay
and so let's settle for the randomizing
on average and the notion of average
throughout this stock will be success 99
or 1 minus one over n over the uniform
distribution so it's a very weak notion
and the goal is to optimize the
Assumption get something normal
maybe standard hardness worst case
hardness for probabilistic algorithms or
something like that
maybe even something that's intuitive
that we can understand or at least
imagine that we understand and it's weak
this is a context that kind of Unites
three different kinds of work
in this area which was separate so far
one that was started by Russell and Avi
25 years ago another one that was
started by Avi and other goldrike 20
years ago and another one that isn't a
line of work it is a work but it's
separate and related it's by Marco
Russell and Manuel Sabin from four years
ago five times five flies fast so part
of what's going on here is that we're
going to unite them all and give them
one context
uh let's do it's like an action movie
right we need to start with an action
sequence then the exposition
okay so this is the actual action
sequence it's like jumping ahead this is
a sample theorem here's the sort of
thing we're gonna do today so assume
that counting K clicks on an invert X
graph takes probabilistic time end to
the log star of K
right not n to the K and to the
something that grows with K I don't care
how weekly grows then RP equals p on
average
the notion of average is 99 over the
uniform distribution
what I find interesting in this
statement we're going to prove more
General versions and stronger Stuff Etc
but what I find interesting here is that
I can understand the Assumption or at
least I can imagine that I understand it
right K clicks and to Decay how can we
optimize them to the log circuit sounds
very believable when I look at it and
that the conclusion is surprisingly
strong
because the Assumption looks like pretty
appealing to me like oh yeah sure and
the conclusion is suddenly like okay
polynomial time the randomization maybe
of one-sided error maybe with like error
on one percent of the inputs but still I
wouldn't have expected that
sorry technology
yes we're going to have a rug and stick
it in under the rabbit but this holds
almost everywhere no problem
next in this particular aspect all the
results today will actually be good but
I want to hide it like promises IO
versus almost always everything does not
talk about the presence
right yeah what's the fastest algorithm
we know for counting categies
is there a cake person in there it's
actually
Omega K over 3 where Omega is Major
smallest one yeah
that's it okay so enter the cable too we
don't know anything we've been into the
table too like the right answer the
result from like uh of Marco and NASA
Emmanuel would avoid him enough
is
[Music]
foreign
which
okay so if you are the formerly for
every single in this case
okay we'll move past the action sequence
this is our plan for today I'm going to
start with something boring and weird
that's really important it's a classical
missing piece in hardness versus
Randomness basically something doesn't
scale as we think it should scale we've
been stuck for 25 years on it this is
the first substantial progress that as
far as I'm aware of and while it might
be okay so something scales I mean fine
we've been stuck for a long time maybe
that's not the most appealing thing but
I'm gonna talk about it in depth and
this will be what we need to make
progress on natural and intuitive stuff
such as counting K clicks versus
randomization it's going to be important
then I'm going to talk about natural and
intuitive stuff the counting K clicks
the more General problems I'm going to
end by giving some poor constructions
and proof ideas of what's going on here
let's start by something that I have
demotivated you about the classical
missing piece in hardness versus
Randomness so the context now is not the
new non-black box versions of hardness
versus Randomness we're going back to
the 90s okay
classical hardness versus randomness
so the main focus of the classical stuff
in textbooks that we teach and write
about is a formal equivalence between
lower bounds for circuits and prgs for
circuits for example the classical
results of Russell and Avi following sun
and Victor's son like okay exponential
time is hard for circuits of exponential
size if and only if there are prgs that
would give you BPP equals p
and we also note that these scales there
was a lot of work put in to make it
scale well that work was put in in the
late 90s and early 2000s and it was
successful so let's parse this okay
we're starting with a function
computable in exponential time which is
an intuitive thing to do when you do the
randomization because you're gonna
you're going to compute the entire truth
table so exponential time and what is
the hardness that we assume we can
assume hardness for all polynomial size
circuits and we can increase the
hardness maybe up to exponential size
circuits
and as we increase the hardness the the
randomization that we get from it
becomes faster in a smooth way like if
it's a hardness for poly side circuits
and you get two to the end to the
Epsilon time if it's hardness for
exponential size circuits you'll get BPP
equals p and you're happy and don't pass
this just it's a smooth
and the point that I want to make is
that there is a second line of Works in
hardness versus Randomness that does
something different
it shows an equivalence hiding IO versus
a under drug between lower bounds for
algorithms just normal probabilistic
algorithms not circuits these are a bit
more natural and weaker lower bounds and
average case the randomization of PPP
such as the one we're talking about
today
so for example again a 25 year old
result exponential time is hard for BPP
if and only if BPP can be de-randomized
in sub-exponential time on average
this is the type of thing in the
secondary line of work in hardness
versus Randomness and when I started my
PhD I kind of assumed that hardness
versus Randomness is done like we know
everything right
this is a rug we are hiding stuff in
underneath it okay don't ask about
infinitely often almost always don't ask
about the distributions over which we're
average case I'm being fair I'm hiding
good things and bad things in equal
amount
okay
so this is what you'd expect to be true
for the uniform setting hardness for
algorithms versus average case to
randomization the same thing you put in
you'd get in the end you can also you
can also show that it's necessary so
it's it should be obvious that this is
what's true except that what we know is
still the same thing
that we knew 25 years ago in the
original book something like this
as you increase the hardness the best
thing that you can get is like half
exponential time the organization
foreign
okay I'm going to talk like for a while
today in this lecture and in the end for
the general setting we're still going to
remain with this picture
so like if you remember something
remember this open problem which is
great I mean okay something doesn't
scale how come it's been 25 years and we
don't know how to scale it there's an
interesting technical problem
let me explain what this technical
problem is okay all the proofs in this
line of work go by reconstruction
arguments if you can break the prg you
can compute the hard function right the
function is hard you can compute it find
the prg is secure that's the main idea
and like if the Reconstruction argument
hardwire some non-uniform advice
then if we break the prg we compute the
hard function with a circuit a
non-uniform circuit assume circuit Roll
Bounce you're done this is the main line
of work
now if you we only want to assume
hardness for algorithms
we want to make sure that the
Reconstruction here is totally uniform
doesn't hardwire any non-uniform advice
so a uniform reconstruction argument and
the only problem is that we don't know
how to do it
for an arbitrary function in exponential
time the uniform reconstruction is
highly efficient
what leads us to this half exponential
thing
okay there's a classical idea on how to
overcome this
the classical idea it's already implicit
in the original work it was crystallized
later like most prominently by travisan
and batan instead of assuming hardness
for an arbitrary function in exponential
time
let's assume hardness for specific
functions that we can actually work with
they have nice properties a downward
self-reducible and random self-reducible
for example the permanent
um
so satisfies this and also there are
other constructions of nice functions
that satisfy this small artificial ones
and then we know how to do this uniform
reconstruction because we have the nice
properties and we're leveraging them
so for example like uh later on and I
and also with the Elon you'll give a
couple of years ago really crunch the
parameters of something along these
lines and got something like this so
instead of exponential time fix a
specific function in P space it's as a
tqbf totally Quantified Boolean formula
someplace based complete language assume
hardness for this function specifically
then you get something that's kinda
nicer maybe okay if you get a bit of
better parameters
like everything's Quantified everything
and okay it's a specific function and
notice this is the polynomial thing so
we're not getting it together again so
find this is what was known
the limitations of the previous
classical idea was that such functions
with knights properties exist only in P
space provably
even if you relax the nice properties
it's still in subclasses of exponential
time
can't wait also these are specific
functions so either you assume hardness
for this particular function
or you assume hardness for something
else and reduce to this function paying
polynomial overheads and losing into
their normalization these are your two
choices
the third problem is that the known
functions with the nice properties are
easy or they're not really easy but
they're solvable in less than
exponential time you would never get
polynomial times or anomalization from
these functions they cannot be
exponentially hard
and the fourth problem is that all the
previous arguments incurred runtime
overheads so even if you would solve all
of this you would still not get
polynomial
and the main contribution in this weird
classical missing piece part
is this
okay
it's something that's better
it's not optimal we haven't nailed it
yet the problem is still open but there
is progress on stuff that we really
didn't know how to make progress so
what's going on this is a class it's not
one function
and this class
probably con it contains linear space
and probably extends far beyond this
space so we broke through that's good
and we get polynomial time dynamization
any function in the class would do it
doesn't need to be a specific one
and also these functions can actually be
exponentially hard right in contrast to
the previous known ones
and the sad part is that it's only the
randomization with one-sided there it's
basically only RP
let me State this formally
so this the class would be the class A
functions computable in exponential time
and depth 2 to the little frame
so log space uniform circuits of size 2
to the n and that two to the little o of
n
and like if you have exponential
hardness then you get uh polynomial time
the anonymization and it scales quite
well not perfect because we have this
little bulge here but forget about it
that's not
there's still a lot of work to be done
this is only for RP you can do BPP but
you need to pay some advice so like if
you want to do polynomial tender
randomization you're paying
logarithmically many bits of advice
it's not perfect
note that this class contains linear
space right by repeated squaring
squaring The Matrix you can also always
simulate like uh linear space and like
size 2 to the n and depth you know
polynomial right let alone two to delete
low of n so this class seems much larger
than P space and we don't need any
special structure of any function there
any function in the class would do
conceivably this class should have
functions that are exponentially hard
and we get polynomial time dynamization
the sad part is only one-sided error
it's not fully exponential time the
trade-off has a bulge in the middle
so
that's basically it that's all I wanted
to say about the missing piece in
hardness versus Randomness the classical
stuff
we got some progress
the point here isn't that we're done I'd
like to still highlight the open problem
we are not done yet even with classical
hardness versus Randomness stuff even
though we're moving towards the new
non-blackbox approaches so I'm
highlighting the open problem and the
fact that there is a substantial
progress here on stuff that we didn't
know how to do for a long time is what
paves the way for progress and what I'm
about to show next
any questions before I move on
yeah
foreign
let's talk about the randomization from
intuitive stuff
the motivating question is can we reduce
randomization from stuff we understand
and of course the nicest setting is
fine-grained hardness in because we feel
like we understand problems in P better
than exponential time
so now we wanted to do sterenomization
from fine grade hardness in p and the
main point to highlight here is that
this question means that we're trying to
do something harder
because hardness up there in exponential
time is a stronger assumption than
hardness Below in polynomial time so
right now we want to reduce the
randomization from weaker assumptions
intuitive natural we can understand but
weaker so we're going to need to work a
bit in particular the results here
Builds on the results before with some
extra improvements
there's one line of work
called typically correct the
randomization is Guided by ordered some
20 years ago their original intention
was different but it ended up showing
things like this
so this is by Cleveland
no sorry yeah thank you sorry
so here is a result assume that for
every constant C there is a language in
P can depend on C right so this is like
a c and this is n to the 100 C the
running time or something like that
that's hard for circuits of size n to
the C where the hardness is like mild
average case hardness every circuit
fails on like one over n of the inputs
then VPP equals p on average
what's going on here
this is a very clean result of the type
that we are looking for this is just
fine-grained hardness in p a problem in
P that's hard for Diamond to the C right
the most General thing you can imagine
but the hardness is for non-uniform
circuits our entire goal here was to get
rid of non-uniform circuits and stuff
that we don't understand this is the
drawback and also we need some mild
average placeholders like every circuit
fits on like one percent of rain boots
or one overhead
okay just basically some of the director
of the heart functions
some some questions
with what you're saying maybe you can
get regardless
the property will need to get a uniform
analog of such attention like they say
no to say oh there's a function between
the transfer probabilistic time n to the
20 and that gives bbp equals p on
average I'd be really happy that's a
clean statement
uniform hypothesis is also necessary for
such effects great
the other line of focus called uh it is
a work problem-centric randomization
this is a work I mentioned by Marco
Russell manually Sabin this is uh there
are a couple of results there this is
one of them it's representative assume
that for every K accounting K clicks is
hard for probabilistic algorithms
running in time and to Decay over two
basically
okay it's great this is enough BPP
equals p on average it's great because
like it's only worst case hardness it's
for probabilistic algorithms it makes
sense to us but it's really the upper
bound and the lower bound are tied are
tied together and to the K versus n to
the K over two and it's a specific
problem it's not a family of problems
there are a couple of problems that are
very specific here you need to assume
hardness for for the same reason that I
talked about before in this classical
missing paste thing these problems have
this type of downward self-reducibility
or and random self-reducibility
properties at least when you will
hypnotize them a little bit so that was
the reason we needed these specific
problems
sorry this looks very close to what you
had at the beginning in the action
sequence can you you just compare this
to your action sequence of course in the
action sequence you need the hardness I
don't know where to look you need the
hardness to grow like as any growing
function of K like and to the log star
of K here you need basically enter the K
over too
okay
that makes sense so that's the main
difference okay yes well I'm going to
show something more General in a second
okay all right thanks it's used to be
interesting randomization yeah
so for example eth
implies your hypothesis but not but not
ours yeah okay I didn't notice that
because maybe it's effectively like
saying County K clicks is not fpt world
yeah there's no idea true very cool
but I'm going to show again something
more General than that give me a second
okay so let's uh what we want we want
more General functions than these
specific functions so assume that here
here are two theories okay the first is
assume that for every state there's a
function computable in polynomial time
and depth N squared Lu is log space
uniform forget about uniform circuits
polynomial time and depth N squared
that's hard for probabilistic time and
to the C with the the smiled average
then our pay will be on average
this gets close to what we want to get
in the like by analogy to the
non-uniform setting except that we're
restricting the depth to be N squared
I'm not really sure how to eat and pass
this statement except that it's nice and
it compares to the non-uniform one so I
have something that's more intuitive now
assume that for every C there's a
function computable by arithmetic
formulas of polynomial size and degree N
squared over a field of large polynomial
size that's hard for probabilistic time
n to the C let's pass this slowly this
is like the punch line here okay
this contains stuff like uh
K sum K click when I was just count in
parallels like arithmetic formulas but
this is likely a much more General class
you can solve all the problems that you
can just brute force and count but it
can solve many other things
if there is a function in this class any
function that's hard for probabilistic
time n to the C like
for every C you can find the function
then you get RP equals p on average and
the K click example was just one
instance here so Okay click example is
supposed to be a special case of this it
is a special case of basis oh okay well
so then that means that this is some
language so you're thinking of
arithmetic and binary and then you
construe the output of that arithmetic
formulas
it's not a language right
it's a function
oh yeah yeah
so you either get the field element in
the end or you do something where you
could actually refill the elements
okay you can do it with languages too
but it doesn't have to be
any other questions
I'm gonna move on
please
store the number of leads
all right
so the hardest is for a true sighted
stories
the rest would be like a proof ideas
okay that's the perfect business so this
is a proof idea of how to use this
result recently as a black box from the
previous one let's do it because I think
we have time okay assume that uh I
already convinced you of this thing
because the paper is published so it's
probably true right so this thing is
true so now let's prove theorem three
based on it so we're starting with a low
degree formula like a formula of degree
N squared
you know that you can balance formulas
if the degree is unsquared probably the
like we can do it in small depth too
just
balance it very efficiently keep it
small degree keep it log space uniform
so not so now let's assume that we have
like uh N squared probably much lower
than that right let's say N squared
depth formulas great we're already at
the set close to the setting before
because now everything has depth N
squared
and now we just need to amplify worst
case hardness to mild average case
hardness but that shouldn't be hard
because we are arithmetic already this
is a low degree polynomial over a large
finite field
so just okay we're done you know okay we
got my leverage case hardness that's it
there are so some details here but
that's the plan and it doesn't it
doesn't go wrong too much
great
so now all I have to convince is a fear
M2
yeah
a high level question like uh so you've
proved you know too like uh what would
you like want to prove next here like
what would be is how we move then
squared
[Music]
and that seems very difficult
um
necessary conditions for that is to
remove the two to the middle of a friend
in the classical instance of this thing
I don't want to do that
thank you
oh yeah
oh yeah okay true yeah
there's an open problems
all right let's put them into okay the
basic building block was something from
a previous work called glitter so I
found something we did for non-black
boxing organization so it's uh all the
builders we find there's a targeted
heating set generator
and this is the construction for the
previous 4K fixed parameters so that
things would be nice let's de-randomize
linear time yes fun okay so for every
function in like uh that has computable
in time n to the 100 and depth N squared
right there is a corresponding targeted
heating set generator the function was F
the heating saturnator depends on F so
it's h sub f
and it satisfies the following the
heating saturator gets an input X reads
the input and prints a list of n bit
strings that depends on the input and
the guarantee is the following for every
linear time machine M and every fixed
input X so now we fix the input
available to all parties
if you can break the prg on X then you
can compute the hard function on x
if the heating set generator doesn't hit
the linear time machine and the linear
time machine tends to accept all strings
the standard function of not being so
the random for hitting set generator
then there's a fixed algorithm that
depends on the machine runs in time n to
the 10 and manages to compute the
function on this particular input
so breaking the targeted prg when it's
targeted to that input means Computing
the hard function when the input to the
hard function is this particular one
and it generalizes we're going to use
the same thing in the exponential range
Let's ignore this the key Point here is
that hardness on an input means so
Random on the same input and that any
function in the class would
you don't need any special properties
other than being in this class
so here's the plan and here's where it
will go wrong
it's a kind of where we started from
like for sure it should work except that
there's a missing part let's just use it
okay let's start with a function that's
hard in the worst case
now do all the usual tricks that we know
how to do in complexity Theory and get a
function that's harder 99 of the inputs
so worst case to average case reductions
and then just you know feed it to the
targeted heating set generator and
that's it
the second part Works no problem the
first part we just it was not known
now I'm not saying that this is
something like uh inconceivable because
we're not we're going to do it in a
second but it did require new technical
tools okay so this is still the high
level plan and the main technical
contribution going forward would be to
show this type of thing worst case to
average case reductions that are
hopefully optimal and hold for the
relevant classes
not exponential time cryptographic
assumptions like learning with errors
you can get these
things generically how how this compared
to such statements
[Music]
okay no okay you need you need to just
be like the algae function with a lot of
output you know to even possibly be hard
yeah
because
when you can use volume of encryption or
even other cryptographic assumptions to
take an edge this so replacing F by G
will not be good enough
yeah
this is it should be as primary that's
not that's not the issue so you're
saying that certain assumptions just as
a statement suppose you could prove your
conclusion but let's throw in an
assumption that lwe is not in the usual
case how would that compare it would be
more specialized but then basically I'm
interested in knowing more about it I
don't want to do it
encryption to do a random self-reduction
not random yeah yeah
okay I just want to mention that like
one bit that I don't think foolingo was
a conviction because this is
unconditional but I want to know about
it regardless okay
we're going to start with worst case
assumptions
okay let's do let's see where things
break when we want to do more space to
average space reductions without this uh
what the polio morphic encryption
so it's in the usual Way start with the
problem such at every end to the 20
algorithm fails to compute it on a small
chunk of inputs like 1 over n and call
the truth table of that function to
another truth table by an efficient it's
approximately locally least decodable
code the standard thing that we want
that we know how to do and if this
sounds like mumbo jumbo do direct
products take a direct product okay no
problem do it multiple times and now
like if the original function was higher
than a small chunk of inputs the new
function should be hard on
true okay I shouldn't say worst case
because now we are trying to prove this
too my mild average case to Stronger
which case
so we do direct folder and now the new
thing should be hard on most inputs I
mean we've all heard this statement a
million times before
but we're usually used to reading this
statement for circuits not for AdWords
let's see what goes wrong
okay let's put try to prove it and see
where we get stuck let's start with an
algorithm that computes the direct
product well on a big chunk of inputs
like one over n it shouldn't be able to
do that let's plug in the local list
decoder it would be like the decoder
with Oracle access to the usual thing
right at least the code using Oracle
access to the corrupted function and now
the list decoder should compute the
original function on most inputs that's
the guarantee because it's approximately
correct the problem here really is that
ballistic alternates the index in the
list
because without an index it just
succeeds with low probability
okay we don't know how to produce this
index when we are a uniform algorithm by
ourselves
so okay there's a classical patch not
the first time people who are dealing
with this have heard the notion of an
instance Checker Let's Build an instant
Checker an instance tracker for a
function is a machine
Etc if you give it Oracle access to that
function it can compute the function
which is not very impressive but it also
satisfies the soundness condition if you
give it Oracle access to anything else
it either still computes the function or
it says like you're a lime liar that's
and outputs is superb and goes okay so
this is an instance tracker we know of
constructions of instance checkers
they're going to lose a bit in the
parameters they're not going to be good
enough for this setting but let's
pretend that they don't
we're going to build an instance Checker
in a few slides that's very good with
respect to parameters it's essentially
optimal great let's plug in an instance
tracker and see what happens here
okay revised approach we built the
instance Checker with optimal parameters
the function is hard every algorithm
fails with a mild average customer chunk
of inputs reduce it to a problem that
has a good instance Checker in linear
time preserve all the hardness assume
that everything works well now encode it
with a direct product and go home
everything works right
the tiny little problem okay an instance
tracker works when you give it access to
the original function
okay it doesn't get access to the
original function gets hardness to
something that's kind of close to it has
small corruption
which usually instance checkout this
isn't a big deal
it's usually instant Checkers kind of
spread their queries you know firmly
they make random queries the instance
tracker that we will build here that has
good parameters within a linear time
reduction does not spread its queries
uniformly at all like if you put in a
small corruption you can kill it
okay let's define a tolerant instance
Checker which does exactly what you
think it does
okay so the soundness is just as before
and if you start with a function that
agrees with the original one or 99 of
inputs then you're correct on 99 of
what's the definition
that's Bill Dates
we're done good and I'm I'm hiding some
stuff under the rug again because I want
to say I'm making you think of like a
tolerating such records that are
tolerant and like 99 get you 99 or 98
we're really going to need like
something like even one percent gets you
0.9 percent
because of annoying infinitely often
versus almost always issues
so having said that just to keep in mind
that this notion of tolerant instance
trackers you can push it to the extreme
let's forget about it and think about
the 99
now the approach works okay with the
tolerant instance Checker that just do
what you want to do start with the
function we do sit in linear time to
another function that has a great
tolerant instance tracker encode it with
a direct product you're done that's the
proof plan
with some
visiting details about all the stuff
that's hidden under the rugged works
and this is the main proposition that's
Technical and underlying it every
function in the class is reducible in
linear time to a function basically the
same class you're going to pay a little
bit but you're not going to be too
concerned about it
the size increases the running time
increases polynomially
the depth increases by something that's
not important in this setting
that has a tolerant instance Checker
that is make square is only on the same
length of input so it's good for
preserving all these IO versus a stuff
and the transient small time like a
fixed Universal polynomial n and all the
other stuff will also be
so once in time into the five to say
and I'm going to say how we build it but
I'm going to make a small tangent there
are a lot of tangents here with some
work because this is like a this is a
tolerant instance tracker it would give
us a worst case to average case
reduction or mild average case two
strong average case reduction for this
class which isn't the class I assume
that like you spend much of your life
thinking about I haven't
but with some additional work we can
make it go through for p space and get
an optimal worst case to average case
reduction for probabilistic algorithms
Computing functions in linear space
which wasn't known before the best thing
that I know before is 20 years old and
it has that polynomial overhead so
you're going to lose
so there's a function that's complete
for linear space and the linear time
reduction and has a great tolerant
instance Checker it gives you the
optimal worst case to average space this
is actually the worst case to average
case reduction for probabilistic
algorithms versus linear space
talk about how to build an instance
Checker an instance tracker intuitively
is a proof system
and those were built in the past by
proof systems
and this one is also going to be built
using a proof system just a doubly
efficient proof system
specifically the one by Goldwater Circle
we're going to Maps start with the
function we want to reduce it to another
function that has a great instance
Checker the input to the original
function is X
and at the high level hiding some
details the inputs to this uh function
that has an instance Checker is X which
is the exact same thing and I and J
where I indicates around in the doubly
efficient proof system from 1 up to say
N squared
and J indicates what is the message that
the verifier sends in this round
that what the function gives back is the
Proverbs answer right this is the
basically the proverb strategy function
uh pretend that the proof system is
history and dependent right the prover
just answers according to what the
verifier said in this round
in actuality in gkr it's almost history
independent like it depends only on a
constant number of previous rounds which
allows us to pretend this
so if it's at if it would have been
actually independently so independent
this would have been definition it's
almost so it's approval because the
response here needs to be to depend on
like a hundred James
here
and then you just mean that like if the
previous optimal strategy is the same
like with say the last few rounds only
in the transcripts as opposed the whole
transcript or whatever it might be round
dependence like the proof of strategy is
different in the second round and in the
third one but it doesn't the proof the
proof strategy in the third round
doesn't depend on what the verifiers
said in the second left
but usually you have the entire
transcript and you go one is like all
but the last bit of the transcript can
be omitted it doesn't matter exactly and
it's not really the last bit it's the
100 bit perspective
foreign
you can't cheat by just like having
another
like this one if you want independence
from the third round for the first round
in some sense or totally depend on the
next round you can somehow
okay okay
I think what I've seen doesn't make
sense oh if it would make sense later
I'll be glad to hear it
starting to check about the parameters
say okay there aren't too many rounds
right less than the running time so like
uh if the input had n Bits adding this
one and the clogan Beats I don't care
and the number of coins that the
verifier uses in this proof system isn't
too large
so basically it's a linear time
reduction that's my point right I'm
mapping these type of inputs to this
type of inputs how does the linear time
reduction go okay you give me X I want
to reduce this new problem well let's
assume that the prover the first thing
that it does after it wakes up in the
morning is say what the value of the
function is
so just uh okay this will be zero and
zero and we're done X goes to X zero
zero good the approver is efficient
that's it's a doubly efficient proof
system which means that the complexity
of the problem is preserved
that's the point of using a double
efficient proof system here right
deciding this new problem the prover
strategy functions is not too hard
compared to the original problem
and the very far in the double efficient
proof system was super efficient that's
also appropriately which means that the
instance Checker that we'll get is also
very fast
how will the instance tracker work
it would do the obvious thing it would
simulate the proof system it would say
okay what do you say in the first round
good now let me choose a message in the
first in the second round and challenge
you again and again until we're done if
the approver is correct we're good if
not then okay good
this is it it works actually this is the
description of the entire Construction
the only problem is that it's not
tolerant right of course if the prover
is is good then we're going to be happy
but if like uh you know 1 over n of the
proverb strategy functions are corrupted
then we have no guarantee and in fact
it's not hard to construct counter
examples here for this specific proof
system
okay I'll just corrupt the last two
rounds
okay it's uh actually not a big deal
this is what I want to say you can turn
it into a tolerant thing and it's not a
big deal so instead of like having
around Let's uh uh the answer here would
be the answer according to a polynomial
that interpolates the polynomials in all
rounds and instead of just giving it a
number of around give it something in a
larger domain so now okay if someone is
trying to corrupt this specific area
a precise question you're interested in
um you can say that like there will be a
specific question that you're interested
in but then you're going to use
self-correction so basically you're
going to spread out your quiz in your
phone
is that what you were thinking of when
you say hiding the question okay then
yes
that's it it actually works this is
basically the description we're done
that's a tolerant instance Checker if
you want to look at the details of the
instance record or in the paper they
give you optimal worst case to average
case reductions for linear space and I
think I have a minute which is perfect
for the open problems
slide Rahul your open problem is uh the
second one here
so let's start okay as I said the
missing piece in hardness versus
Randomness before going to this fine
grain stuff just get the BPP equals p on
average from hardness in exponential
time we honestly don't know how to do it
it's a fantastic open question because
we've been stuck on it for so long
after we're done with it let's do the
the harder thing the trouble wants to do
reduce BPP equals p on average from fine
grained hardness in P like a functioning
P that's hard for time n to the 10.
uh do the thing that legio wants to do
strengthen the conclusion to BPP equals
p on average instead of RP equals p
there's a fantastic open problem hiding
here too how to merge prgs for uniform
algorithms like uh just one of them
Works merge all of them to a merge one
that works I know how to construct a
heating step generator just take the
union no problem I don't know how to
merge them to a prg and uh there was a
barge in the trade-off so let's maybe
the first thing that will lead the way
to progress is if we focus on getting
smooth stuff it will generate ideas to
play Let's solve the big open problems
20 seconds late thank you very much
[Applause]
questions
should be obvious but can you go back
um
there's constructions that go from
hitting sets to krgs like the tournament
construction or the one
um but either work for circuits or work
for Blackboard
great perfect thank you this is
non-blackbox and foreign
hold your applause
because we're going to thank the speaker
but we're also going to thank the
organizers as is customary but also if
you remember this whole week started off
with uh uh something that I was taking a
little bit by surprise by but it was
very gratifying and I also went to
extend the special personal thank you to
the organizers for that uh special day
that they organized so thank everybody
[Applause]
thank you